Aujourd'hui, on part en voyage ! J'ai décidé
de vous faire découvrir la Suisse et de
vous donner une petite idée de la richesse de
ses paysages et de la culture helvétique .
Et la surprise, c'est que je ne suis pas seul pour
faire ce voyage, je suis avec Benjamin Friant.
Ben, allez, c'est parti ! La Suisse, c'est par là !
Pour commencer notre voyage, je vous proposede rejoindre Ben à Montreux
à bord d'untrain mythique, le GoldenPass Panoramic.
Jamy, je suis actuellement avec Niklaus, il va nous éclairer un petit peu sur la particularité de ce train : le MOB - GoldenPass.
On se retrouve dans le GoldenPass Panoramic. C'est un train un peu spécial avec les grandes vitres.
C'était le MOB, le chemin de fer Montreux-Oberland-Bernois, il y a eu cette idée de construire des voitures pareilles, en 1976
pour nos 75 ans d'anniversaire de notre entreprise. Donc c'est un peu la grande découverte à l'époque et puis, ce sont les autres chemins
de fer qui ont fait des répliques après  de ce train panoramique.
La vue a l’air vraiment chouette, ça donne envie en tout cas !
Depuis 1905, cette ligne de chemin de fer relie Montreux à Zweisimmen. Le parcours dure un peu plus de deux heures
fait 63 kilomètres au total, et son point culminant se situe près de Gstaad, à 1 275 mètres d’altitude.
Le train offre donc toute une palette de panoramas, en partant des bords du lac Léman jusqu’aux paysages alpins de Zweisimmen.
Le parcours permet de découvrir différents pans de la culture suisse, comme par exemple la fabrication de nombreux fromages.
Vous rejoignez les deux bords, puis vous passez de ce côté de l'anse. Puis on la pend un instant sur l'anse pour qu'il s'égoutte.
Voilà. J'ai aidé à mettre du fromage là.
Mmmm, il sent bon la Suisse ce fromage. Mais il n’y a pas que du fromage en Suisse, il y a aussi des ballons.
Une des destinations les plus connues sur le trajet du GoldenPass, c'est bien entendu Château-d'Oex.
Château-d'Oex est hyper connu pour son événement chaque année de ballons dirigeables.
Ça se passe en janvier tous les ans et ce musée retrace l'histoire des ballons de cet événement.
Et pendant cet événement annuel, il y a des milliers de ballons qui sont réunis et qui volent toute la journée.
Ça doit vraiment être une expérience incroyable quand même.
Le train à bord duquel circule Ben a une autre particularité :
il relie le canton de Vaud, où l’on parle français, et le canton de Berne, où l’on parle majoritairement allemand.
L'arrêt qu'on vient de passer là, c'est Rougemont. Je me souviens j'avais fait un camp d'école ici. Et le prochain arrêt, c'est ?
C'est Saanen. C'est déjà dans le canton de Berne.
Donc ici on parle que le
français et après on traverse la fameuse barrière
de Rösti, comme on appelle ça, pour arriver dans le canton de Berne, puis là-bas, on parle que le suisse allemand.
Donc en fait, en quelques mètres, en quelques centaines de mètres, on passe du français à l'allemand.
C'est comme ça en Suisse, il y a des villages qui sont bilingues. Mais là, il y a vraiment une frontière de la langue entre les deux villages
c'est assez fou. Tout à fait, donc c'est une frontière de la langue mais on a quand même tous un petit peu la mentalité
parce qu'on est tous des montagnards.
La Suisse est un pays multilingue. Il y a quatre langues officielles. Au centre du pays, on parle majoritairement allemand.
A l’ouest, le français, et au sud, l’italien. Une minorité de Suisses,
0,5% de la population pour être précis, parlent également le romanche. Cette diversité de langues
s’explique par la position de la Suisse, qui partage ses frontières avec l’Allemagne,la France,
le Liechtenstein, l’Autriche et l’Italie. Je vous propose maintenant de retrouver Ben, à bord d’un autre train mythique qui emprunte
le même chemin de fer : le GoldenPass Belle Époque.
Niklaus, est-ce que tu pourrais nous parler un petit peu de ce train emblématique ?  C'est un train unique parce qu'il est de style
Belle Époque, des années 1930, et il n’y en a pas d'autres en Suisse de ce style.
Il roule tous les jours dans un horaire régulier. Au chemin de fer MOB - Montreux-Oberland-Bernois, nous avons des voitures similaires
depuis les années 1914-15 déjà, donc c'était même une collaboration avec la Compagnie Internationale des Wagons-Lits
à Paris. Donc ce train part de Montreux et il va jusqu'où ?
De Montreux, il grimpe sur Les Avants, Château-d'Oex, Gstaad et il se termine à Zweisimmen.
C'est dans la vallée de la Simme. Là bas, les gens, ils continuent puis ils changent de train pour aller en direction de l'Interlaken de Berne.
Arrêtons-nous quelques instants à Berne.
Cette ville se distingue par son centre historique classé au patrimoine mondial de l’UNESCO. Mais ce n’est pas tout !
Berne est également connue pour avoir hébergé un certain Albert Einstein.
On connaît tous Albert Einstein, on a tous entendu parler de lui. Moi, personnellement, j'ignore complètement où est-ce qu'il a vécu ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé dans sa vie, à part le fait qu'il ait trouvé la théorie de la relativité ?
Il est né à Ulm en 1879. En Allemagne, donc.
Mais ses parents ont, tout de suite, après deux ans, changé de domicile. Ils sont allés vers Munich.
Là, il a fréquenté les écoles avec sa sœur Maya. Et quand il était au lycée, avec une autorité prussienne
ça lui déplaisait totalement. Il est parti à 15 ans, sans diplôme. Il savait très bien qu’il voudrait étudier.
Et ensuite, de nouveau, ses parents sont partis vers l'Italie. Il les a suivis. Mais il trouvait : “Non. Je cherche un pays démocratique"
et c'était la Suisse ! Il a vécu à Berne, donc ?
Il a vécu à Berne depuis 1902 jusqu'en 1909. Quand il avait terminé ses études à Zurich, il ne trouvait pas d'emploi.
Alors il a travaillé comme instituteur auxiliaire. Mais il savait très bien que ça ne fonctionnait pas.
Et pendant les études, il a fait connaissance de Mileva. Naturellement, il l’a adorée parce qu'elle était aussi intelligente que
lui. Et les deux se sont promis : “le premier qui a un emploi, on va s'épouser.”
Albert Einstein et Mileva Maric ont été mariés pendant une dizaine d’année, de 1903 à 1914. Période au cours de laquelle le physicien a publié
une grande partie de ses travaux révolutionnaires. Mileva, elle-même physicienne, n’a jamais revendiqué sa participation aux grandes
découvertes de son mari. Mais après la publication de certaines lettres, la communauté scientifique a commencé à s’interroger…
Tenez, en 1901, Albert écrit à Mileva :
« Comme je serai heureux et fier quand nous aurons tous les deux,
ensemble, mené notre travail sur le mouvement relatif à une conclusion victorieuse ! »
À la lecture de ces lignes, on se demande quelle a été son implication réelle dans les recherches de son mari.
Bien sûr, cela n’enlève rien au génie d’Albert Einstein. L’enjeu du débat est plutôt de savoir à quel point Mileva l’a aidé, et si elle n’a pas
été victime de l’effet Matilda, une théorie selon laquelle la contribution des femmes scientifiques à la Science est souvent
minimisée au profit des hommes.
Il a vécu assez proche d’ici. La chambre ici était très modeste.
Il y avait quelques chaises, une armoire, un lit très dur.
Mais ce qu'il a fait : il a écrit une lettre à Mileva, il a dit : “Mon Dieu, nous avons un canapé très confortable, nous avons des chaises
vraiment rembourrées, nous avons trois armoires.” Et je pense qu'il a voulu convaincre Mileva de le suivre jusqu’ ici à Berne.
Ah ! Donc, il lui a menti.
Mais je pense qu'il était convaincu qu'il pouvait vraiment faire venir Mileva jusqu'ici à Berne pour qu'elle voit où il vit.
Mais il faut savoir qu'il n'a pas juste des statues de lui un peu partout en ville, ou encore son premier appartement à Berne.
Il y aussi un musée Einstein dans les murs du Musée d'Histoire de Berne et c'est là qu'on va maintenant rencontrer Daniel,
guide et spécialiste du physicien théoricien.
Daniel, on a vu ce matin la maison d'Einstein. On a étudié un petit peu sa vie de famille. Est-ce que tu pourrais nous éclairer
sur ses découvertes. Il fait ses recherches de physique dans ses temps libres. Et c'est incroyable, parce que il est un absolu inconnu
dans la matière de la physique. Et il trouve en une année, 1905, quatre théories qui étaient une révolution.
Donc il n’était pas du tout dans le milieu de la physique ?
Il a fait ses études, il avait aussi quelques collègues,
ici à Berne, avec qui il pouvait discuter ses théories. Mais il n'était pas professeur dans une université.
Il n'avait pas de lien strict aux autres universités et cetera. Il a fait ça plus ou moins seul.
E=mc2. C’est souvent à cette équation que l’on résume les travaux d’Albert Einstein. En réalité, il en a écrit beaucoup d’autres.
Sans rentrer dans les détails, tous les scientifiques s’accordent sur le fait que sa théorie de la relativité générale a révolutionné
la physique moderne. Les travaux d’Einstein ont ainsi permis de mieux comprendre le fonctionnement de notre univers. Rien que ça !
Direction maintenant la région des Trois-Lacs, à l’ouest du pays.
Comme son nom l’indique, elle regroupe trois lacs :
le lac de Morat, le lac de Bienne et le plus imposant : le lac de Neuchâtel, où je vous propose de retrouver Ben.
Salut Jamy, aujourd'hui, tu m'as envoyé au Laténium, à Neuchâtel, en Suisse, pour aller visiter un musée d'archéologie. C'est magnifique.
Bonjour.Enchantée, Géraldine.
Où est-ce qu'on est, aujourd'hui ? On se trouve au Laténium sur la commune d'Hauterive, juste à côté de Neuchâtel
et on est au bord du lac de Neuchâtel.
Petit tour dans le musée, Jamy.
Tu as vu Jamy ? Tous ces outils ont été retrouvés tels quels. Et regarde Jamy, ils ont même retrouvé du pain.
Alors effectivement, ça ne ressemble pas vraiment à du pain comme ça, mais c'est bien du pain. Et là on a même une assiette avec
des restes de nourriture au fond, c'est fou.
En 1868 et 1878, il y a eu ce qu'on appelle la première correction des eaux du Jura qui a créé un abaissement artificiel du niveau
des trois lacs, et notamment de celui du lac de Neuchâtel.
Il y a 150 ans, toute la région était marécageuse et régulièrement inondée par la rivière l'Aar. L’eau envahissait les maisons
et détruisait les cultures. À la fin du 19ème siècle, les autorités décident de réaménager complètement la zone.
Quatre canaux principaux et une série de petits canaux sont construits, ainsi que des barrages. L’objectif : contrôler les eaux
de l’Aar et relier les trois lacs pour en faire des réservoirs de régulation.
Cet immense aménagement est plus connu sous le nom de « Première correction des eaux du Jura ». Ces travaux ont permis
d’abaisser le niveau des lacs d’environ 2 mètres 70 et d’assécher la zone.
Les archéologues ont alors pu avoir accès à des sites préhistoriques. Les fouilles ont mis au jour des milliers d’objets
et des vestiges de maisons sur pilotis, dans lesquelles vivaient les habitants de la région il y a 3 000 ans.
Tout ça a été submergé...
Ouais ! Ça a été conservé dans l'eau, et au moment de la correction
des eaux du Jura, avec, l'abaissement de l'eau...
On a pu découvrir ces objets...
...les gens ont pu aller se servir.
Est-ce que vous avez des ruines, ici ?
Alors c'est vrai que dans le musée on a surtout des petits objets
mais tu verras, dans le parc, on a des reconstitutions un peu plus monumentales de choses qui ont été retrouvées en fouilles
et ça te rappellera peut-être les ruines.
Ok, on y va !
Donc là, on arrive devant une reconstitution.
Exactement ! C'est une reconstitution de maisons lacustres
telles qu'on les construisait à la fin de l'Âge du bronze, c'est à dire il y a 3 000 ans. C'est une reconstitution fidèle à partir d'observations
qui ont été faites sur des sites archéologiques sur les rives des lacs.
Les maisons sur pilotis reposent sur de long pieux en bois profondément ancrés dans le sol, ce qui permet de se protéger
des inondations, de l'humidité et des moustiques !
Il y a un bassin là-bas, c'est pour délimiter justement le niveau ?
Ouais, exactement. En fait, le bassin qu'on peut voir permet
de se rendre compte de la hauteur de l'eau avant la première correction des eaux du Jura.
Le lac est ici et tu vois le mur là-bas ? L'eau du lac arrivait jusqu'au niveau du mur. Ça fait à peu près de 2 mètres 70.
Donc théoriquement là, je suis sous le niveau de l'eau.
À bientôt.
Oui, à très bientôt.
À Neuchâtel.
Après la première correction des eaux du Jura, la région a connu une nouvelle inondation dévastatrice en 1910.
Il a donc fallu renforcer les aménagements en place : un nouveau barrage a été construit et les canaux ont été élargis.
Dernier aménagement en date : la modernisation de la centrale hydroélectrique de Hagneck, sur les rives du lac de Bienne.
Construite en 1900, elle a été totalement modernisée et inaugurée en 2015. Ben, tu nous fais visiter ?
Là, je suis actuellement tout en haut de la centrale. Je ne sais pas si tu vois très bien, mais il y a des tourbillons !
C'est là que l'eau passe dans les turbines, et en fait, les turbines sont vingt mètres dessous là. L'eau passe au travers des turbines,
crée de l'électricité, ressort de l'autre côté. Quand les poissons se retrouvent ici,
pour pas qu'ils se retrouvent coincés en-dessous, il y a des passages pour qu'ils puissent se retrouver de l'autre côté !
C'est énorme !Wouaaah !
Les gros tuyaux bleus que tu as pu voir, c'est par là que l'eau passe et crée de l'électricité au travers des turbines.
Et ces deux grosses turbines permettent de créer de l'électricité pour à peu près 25 000 foyers.
Impressionnant !
Revenons maintenant sur les bords du lac de Neuchâtel.
Suite à la correction des eaux du Jura, les oiseaux se sont appropriés les nouveaux marais apparus sur la rive sud-est du lac.
Ce site s’appelle la Grande Cariçaie, il regroupe huit réserves naturelles sur près de 3 000 hectares.
Jamy, je suis actuellement avec le directeur de l'association BirdLife Suisse. François, bonjour.
Bonjour.
On sait que La Grande Cariçaie est une énorme réserve naturelle,
mais qu'est-ce qu'elle a de spéciale ?
C'est plus exactement un chapelet de réserves naturelles, qui est,
en fait, organisé sur les 40 kilomètres de cette rive du lac de Neuchâtel. C'est un haut lieu pour la diversité biologique.
On rencontre sur cette rive sud un quart des espèces animales et un tiers des espèces végétales, donc des plantes,
qu'on peut rencontrer en Suisse.
Donc c'est vraiment un haut lieu incroyable et qui est préservé
maintenant depuis quelques dizaines d'années, qui est protégé strictement.
Est-ce que vous pourriez nous parler un petit peu de cette association ?
On a à peu près 70 000 membres et puis on travaille beaucoup dans le domaine de la biodiversité.
On utilise souvent les oiseaux comme emblème de la biodiversité.
On s'engage dans des programmes concrets
de conservation de la nature et des espèces. On essaie aussi d'influencer les politiques pour qu'elles soient plus attentives
à la préservation de la nature.
C'est magnifique ici.
C'est beau, hein ? Tu vois on est sur un ponton comme ça,
qui traverse la zone naturelle, ce qui fait que, d'une part, la végétation n'est pas piétinée, on voit que la zone est bien protégée autour.
Puis en même temps, pour la faune, les animaux savent qu'on reste sur ce chemin et qu'en principe on s'écarte pas ce qui fait qu'on arrive
à avoir une cohabitation assez proche entre la faune et l'Homme, quoi.
Le site de la Grande Cariçaie accueille pas moins de 390 espèces d’oiseaux, comme le grèbe huppé, la panure à moustaches,
ou encore la locustelle luscinioïde. En janvier 2021, les ornithologues ont recensé près de 88 000 oiseaux sur le site.
Certains y vivent toute l’année, d’autres, les oiseaux migrateurs, ne font que passer.
C’est le cas, par exemple, d’une espèce de canard, le fuligule morillon. À l’arrivée de l’hiver, il quitte la Sibérie,
s'envole pour la Suisse où il hiverne dans la Grande Cariçaie.
Mais pourquoi cette réserve attire-t-elle autant d’oiseaux ? Et bien parce qu'ils y trouvent un refuge protégé et riche en nourriture.
Au menu : insectes, poissons, mollusques et autres amphibiens.
La Grande Cariçaie leur offre, pour ainsi dire, le gîte et le couvert.
Et donc dans la réserve tout est naturel ?
Ben non. C'est un paysage, en fait, qui est largement influencé par l'homme parce que c'est un milieu qui a une dynamique naturelle
assez forte et en particulier, la forêt a tendance à coloniser toutes ces surfaces de marais,
donc on intervient beaucoup pour maintenir ces valeurs naturelles ici alors.
En fauchant par exemple, C'est ce que tu peux voir sur les parcelles qui se trouvent ici.
Par exemple aussi, en protégeant la rive contre l'érosion avec des palissades de pieux.
Comme ça, on arrive à maintenir cette biodiversité assez extraordinaire qui est dans cette réserve.
On a souvent tendance à penser que l’Homme n’intervient pas dans les réserves naturelles.
Et pourtant, la nature a parfois besoin d’un petit coup de pouce pour trouver son équilibre.
C’est le cas de la Grande Cariçaie, menacée par l’érosion de ses rives. À cause de l’eau et du vent
les rives reculent en moyenne d’un mètre par an !
Pour lutter contre cette érosion,
il est possible d’implanter des palissades en bois parallèles à la rive. Les pieux sont enfoncés profondément au fond du lac
et maintenus au moyen de pierres.
Ces palissades protègent la rive des vagues.
Elles retiennent également les sables. L’objectif est de favoriser l’implantation des roseaux,
afin qu’ils puissent prendre, à terme, le relais des palissades, de manière naturelle.
Regarde ça, Jamy.
Cette plage est incroyable ! Je ne savais pas qu'il y avait ça ici.
C'est fou, je peux comprendre le succès qu'elle a.
Sa particularité, c'est qu'elle est vraiment comprise complètement dans la réserve naturelle.
C'est un peu un pari à l'origine de ces réserves : c'est de faire cohabiter loisirs, tourisme et puis protection de la nature.
Et donc, il y a des zones assez ouvertes au public, comme ici, puis d'autres qui sont plus protégées.
Alors la difficulté à partir de là, c'est que sur une plage comme ça, on peut avoir vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de monde
et puis à partir de là, des gens qui ne respectent pas forcément les réglementations
et puis qui partent de part et d'autre dans la réserve naturelle.
Tu me parlais des paddles entre autres, hein ?
Voilà, ouais.
Le paddle, c'est actuellement une activité qui s'est beaucoup développée, depuis trois quatre ans maintenant.
Et puis c'est vrai que c'est une activité super, assez bon marché. Malheureusement les gens ne sont pas tellement informés
des réglementations et tout, et puis on a souvent des gros dérangements sur les oiseaux de part et d'autre
de cette zone de plage.
C'est vraiment magnifique.
Tu ne regrettes pas trop d'être dans ton studio ?
La prochaine fois, on inverse Ben  : je vais sur le terrain, et je te laisse mon atelier.
En attendant, je te propose de prendre un peu de hauteur.  À 2 000 mètres d’altitude pour être tout à fait exact.
Direction le glacier de Fee, à Saas-Fee dans les Alpes Valaisannes, je pense que ça va te plaire !
Salut Jamy ! Je crois que tu as lu dans mes pensées, parce que tu m'as envoyé dans mon élément naturel :
la montagne. Et plus précisément aujourd'hui, un glacier.
C'est pour ça que maintenant, j'ai rendez-vous avec un guide et ensuite, on va aller faire une petite rando
et peut-être descendre dans des crevasses, histoire de voir un glacier de plus près.
Wow, c’est beau ! On dirait une mer de glace !
Donc on va s'encorder et puis c'est parti !
On arrive à la première crevasse. Ouah ! C'est énorme !
Cette crevasse fait environ 60 m de profondeur, c'est difficile à évaluer comme ça.
Faut pas tomber, une chute de 60 mètres ça fait pas du bien, rester pas trop au bord.
Il y a des toutes petites crevasses, mais ce sont des toutes petites crevasses toutes fines.
Mais elles sont profondes par contre. On ne voit pas le fond, c'est assez fou.
Des petites crevasses comme celles-là, il y en a un peu partout, on ne peut pas vraiment tomber dedans.
On est tombé sur une immense crevasse, c'est presque un canyon, c'est tellement énorme.
Mike qui est en train de préparer la corde et puis après je vais descendre dans la crevasse.
Je ne stresse pas du tout.
Alors, on a compris comment apparaissent les crevasses, mais les glaciers ? Comment se forment-ils ?
Et bien ils naissent, par accumulation de plusieurs couches de neige en montagne. La neige tombe, puis se tasse au fur et à mesure
sous le poids des nouvelles couches de neige qui la recouvrent.
À terme, la neige finit par se transformer en glace bien compacte.
En l’occurrence, les scientifiques estiment que les plus anciennes glaces du glacier de Fee se sont formées il y à 200 à 300 ans,
à la fin du Petit Âge glaciaire.
C'est assez fou, toutes ces bâches ont été installées pour éviter que cette partie fonde et je sais qu'ils font ça dans plusieurs endroits
sur des glaciers pour éviter que le glacier fonde trop vite, parce que c'est le gros gros problème des glaciers,
ils sont tous en train de fondre.
À cause du réchauffement climatique, les scientifiques observent une accélération de la fonte des glaciers.
En Suisse, ils estiment qu'ils ont perdu près de 13% de leur volume en seulement 10 ans.
Jamy, on vient de redescendre du glacier et j'ai quelques petits fun facts pour toi :
depuis que Saas-Fee été créé, ils n'ont que des petites voiturettes électriques. Ah, bah il y en a une qui arrive justement.
C'est un taxi, un taxi électrique.
Donc, toutes ces petites voitures,
ce sont toutes les mêmes quasiment, il y a des petits shuttles un peu partout et c'est électrique.
Il faut savoir que toute l'énergie créée pour la ville et pour les remontées mécaniques
est de l'énergie hydraulique, donc créée par les barrages.
Pour en revenir aux glaciers, j'ai quelques petites questions à poser à un glaciologue, David, on va aller le retrouver tout de suite !
C'est parti !
Et voilà ! Ça y est j'ai retrouvé David le glaciologue
et je vais lui poser quelques questions concernant les glaciers.
Une des questions que je me pose, c'est à quoi sert un glacier ?
Merci beaucoup
Et si nous ne réduisons pas nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre, tous les glaciers suisses pourraient avoir disparu d’ici 2100.
Pour terminer notre tour de Suisse, je vous propose de revenir à notre point de départ, dans le canton de Vaud.
Jamy, je me trouve actuellement dans le Parc naturel régional Jura vaudois et comme tu peux le voir, je ne suis pas tout seul !
Il y a pas mal de vaches ici.
La particularité de cette région, c'est ces murs de pierres.
On va aller rencontrer tout de suite Eric qui est muretier, pour qu'il nous explique un petit peu à quoi servent ces murs et
quelle est la technique qu'il utilise pour les construire.
Bonjour Eric !
Bonjour Benjamin !
En plein travail, je vois.
En plein travail, voilà !
J’ai entendu dire qu'il y en avait à peu près 700 kilomètres de murs dans cette région ?
On estime à peu près 700 km, mais si on prend l'ensemble du Jura, des deux côtés de la frontière, français et suisse,
c'est des milliers et des milliers de kilomètres.
Jamy, Eric va nous montrer comment on construit ces murs, parce qu'il y a une technique très spéciale.
Je construis deux murs qui s'appuient l'un sur l'autre. Tu vois les pierres sont toutes inclinées vers l'intérieur du mur,
de manière à ce qu'elles ne puissent pas s'échapper sur l'extérieur.
En fait, les forces s'annulent, elles sont appuyées l'une contre l'autre, elles ne peuvent pas sortir.
Il faut absolument que le mur soit le plus compact et le plus rempli possible.
Eh oui, c'est vrai qu'on voit bien la forme pyramidale quand on se met de profil.
Voilà c'est ça et pour une question de solidité. Puis ici, on a des pierres qui sont vraiment très irrégulières.
Si on a des pierres vraiment rectangulaires, on peut se permettre de faire un mur plus ou moins vertical,
alors qu'ici c'est des pierres irrégulières donc en général je donne un fruit de l'ordre de 15 à 25%, en général.
Le mur est plus large à la base qu'en hauteur.
Et puis alors, le principe, c'est de mettre des grosses pierres en base pour la stabilité du mur,toujours inclinées vers l'intérieur.
Et puis après, une fois qu'on fait ce mur qu'on arrive à une hauteur donnée, environ 80 à 90 cm,
je finis avec des grosses pierres, qu'on appelle des "couvertes" et qui relient ces deux côtés
et puis comme ça, ça fait un espèce de coffrage, le mur est fermé et normalement tout est coincé, plus rien de bouge.
D'accord. Les tailles en fait, pour qu’elles aient quand même une certaine forme ?
Le moins possible.
Le moins possible ?
Ouais. Parce que j'estime que d'abord c'est perdre du temps, de tailler les pierres, ça peut les fragiliser en fait de les taper.
D'accord.
Alors c'est à moi de me débrouiller pour trouver la pierre qui correspond au trou existant.
Jamy, maintenant ça va être à mon tour ! Eric va me montrer comment on pose les pierres et ensuite ce sera à moi de le faire.
Les murs de pierre sèche sont un héritage du XVIIIe siècle.
Auparavant, les agriculteurs utilisaient le bois pour séparer les propriétés et les parcelles.
Mais ce système était peu durable, en moyenne, les clôtures en bois disparaissaient au bout de 15 à 20 ans.
Et puis les ressources forestières commençaient à chuter dangereusement.
Progressivement, ces clôtures en bois ont donc été interdites au profit des murs de pierre sèche.
Et c’était plutôt une bonne idée, puisqu’ils sont toujours en place. Bon, ça demande quand même un peu d'entretien…
Bon courage Ben !
En fait, on met toujours les plus grosses pierres en bas du mur. Déjà les plus longues parce que le mur est plus large
donc on a plus de place et puis elles sont moins lourdes à porter.
Alors tu vois, celle-ci, tu vois, il y a un profil extérieur, elle irait dans l'autre sens. Ben voilà, c'est pas si mal !
J’ai construit un mur !
Bon, j'ai posé une brique…
Ben voilà... Ce n’est pas trop mal ?
C’est parfait.
Allez, plus que quatre mètres de mur. Eric, tu m'as dit que le mur avait l'utilité de retenir le bétail. Est-ce qu’il a aussi une autre utilité ?
Ça fait un abri pour un tas de petits animaux. En partant des escargots, on trouve des grenouilles, des lézards bien sûr
et puis aussi les hermines qui aiment bien courir dans ces murs et puis justement à la recherche de lézards ou de petites souris.
Et puis justement ici, j'ai trouvé une pierre avec un trou, alors le trou traverse la pierre, donc j'ai fait une petite niche derrière,
grande comme la moitié d'un ballon de football on va dire, et puis ça permettra peut-être à une hermine ou à une souris
de faire sa petite maison.
Les murs de pierre sèche sont un véritable écosystème qui abrite une flore et une faune très diversifiées.
À la surface, les pierres accueillent des mousses, des lichens et même des algues.
Les cavités naturelles creusées par l’Homme, comme on vient de le voir avec Ben
servent quant à elles de refuge à de nombreux animaux, en particulier pendant l’hiver, pour se protéger du froid.
On y trouve des insectes et des petits reptiles, comme les lézards ou les orvets. Mais aussi des mammifères comme l’hermine,
et le campagnol.
Autre avantage, ces murs relient souvent plusieurs milieux naturels entre eux : les pâturages, la forêt, les prairies.
Ils constituent donc des corridors pour les animaux qui peuvent s’y déplacer en toute discrétion, à l’abri des regards.
Regarde Jamy, il y a des spectatrices. Ça va les gars ?
Elles ont l’air sympas tes copines !
J’espère que notre petit tour de Suisse vous aura plu.
En tout cas moi, ça m'a donné faim !  Le plus difficile, c'est de choisir ! Mais je vais faire comme avec la Suisse, un morceau de chaque !